[Music]
there's a part of me that wants it and
this now I proposed here in the sand
dunes do you think re was ready to do
all of this if you're talking about
ready for marriage no I think that I'm
more ready for rims and re is quite
honestly I don't think re knows what he
wants and I don't think he's serious
about being with one person for the rest
of his life even now you don't think no
what makes you say that so well you'll
find out the rest of the season yeah I
just yeah I don't see that okay so how
do you think things will end up for him
even with the choice he's made in the
end I couldn't even what the choice he's
made I don't see him being with this
person for the rest of his life
okay I don't I just don't think I don't
think that's what he wants right now if
he's being honest with himself and
honest with the world okay
well because Ari's been saying that he's
very ready for marry I know he's I think
he's saying that to try to convince
himself and convince everyone who's
watching so why did he go on the show
well who wouldn't want to go on the show
as a bachelor I mean I don't think
there's anything wrong with that and I
think he I think he wants to be ready
for marriage I do I think he wants to
have a wife and like wants to have a
family I believe that I just don't think
he's ready for what comes along with
that kind of commitment I think that Ari
has a conflict between what he wants how
he wants to present himself and what
kind of woman he thinks he should be
with and what kind of woman maybe he
didn't knows he should be with and then
what he really wants I mean you just
don't change dating patterns you've had
for years and years just at the job of a
hat because you're on a TV show like
that doesn't just change overnight and
you bide those patterns you mean like
that he hadn't been in a super serious
relationship he said he doesn't love us
since I'm right or just had this say I
mean he talked about how he hasn't been
with women who are like strong and
independent maybe women's were more
dependent on him and then all of a
sudden you know now who's on the show
and he's like I want a strong
independent woman who I'm an equal with
and I think you see throughout the
season that slowly he kind of eliminated
those women that would be that kind of
presence in a new life so I mean and I
don't think there's anything wrong with
being like yeah I want to be the domina
relationship I mean maybe that's not a
popular thing to say but I wish he would
just be honest about that because I
don't really think that he wanted to be
with a woman like me or women like us
who I think are very strong and who
aren't gonna get him aren't gonna let
him get away with whatever he wants to
get away
[Music]